hello citizens of the reject nation we
are going to watch house of the dragon
episode 3 today johnny how's it going
i'm great i'm excited how are you i'm
excited man heck of a cliffhanger last
episode guys leave a like that'd be
exceptionally appreciated here also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction for house of the dragon is up
here owns this channel and of course
full-length reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy for house
of the dragon over at our patreon page
for super sexy rejects cover plenty of
shows we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included exclusively for those
shows lastly team at prepper thanks for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's swing into action people
[Music]
hardcore what do you think would happen
when you talk to him that way
oh so what a hell of a shot
[Music]
oh i had chills
[Music]
salvation
that was hilarious
[Music]
damn
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
oh damn
this looks great
a tail must do crazy damage in and of
itself he has your hair your face
he does have my hair he has your eyes
yes he does
and you have my nose oh [ __ ]
not today thailand the matter of the
stepstones is regrettably urgent it's
been three years
it can wait another three days it's been
three years i've caught up okay i got
him
renera
yes my queen
your presence is wanted in the outer
courtyard king has much to celebrate he
does not need me he wants for us all to
be together
is it the king's command
yes but then it wants your
grace but it needn't be
none of it needs be this way in truth
reneer up
shut up
[Laughter]
the conqueror second of his name
here's to
[Applause]
[Music]
i love her so much she's so good just
any moment the camera's on or it's so
good
[Laughter]
cuts are i'm like great show great great
show great show best best of the series
your dear uncle is the great mind behind
this wall is he not
i wouldn't know i've not spoken to damon
in years since you supplanted him as
heir damon made his choices lady kira
the princess was more suited to the
wrong you're not my mom
sorry you heard us getting blamed for
some of this [ __ ] yeah
the finest honeyed wine you'll ever
taste made in lannisport of course of
course
[Laughter]
it must be quite something
i don't have a dragon pit of course but
i do have means and resources to build
one
why would you need a dragon head
to house dragons of course
i'd do anything for my queen
smooth lady wife
lannister you
is that what i am to you
a prize to proffer about to the great
houses
this dude's aged like eight years in the
last three years
he's got
well i thought you might have that in
common oh ouch i have tried often to
discuss it with you but you've refused
me at every turn that is because i do
not wish to get married even i do not
exist above tradition and duty ronero
excuse me your grace
your cause it is senior grace
the royal huntsman are sent to report
your grace has been a sighting
of a white heart
the stag is the king of the king's wood
your grace a regal portent for prince
aegon's name day
she's just
part of his imagination
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've always wanted to ride away on a
horse as an angry outlet
better than slamming a door
i had this forged in the golden gallery
in honor of prince aegon it's quite a
thing
i hope it might provide the killing
stroke against your white heart
castley rock is a splendid seat
rhinera may take a place there by my
side without shame
and feel herself well compensated for
her loss in station if you were to name
young aegon air your grace
and when would i be doing that dude dude
slow down on the drone i had a student
as he's your firstborn son someone get
the king some bread
[Laughter]
glass of water over here
i i did not decide to name ronero my
hair
on a whim all the lords of the kingdom
would do well to remember that
thank you
for the gift
oh my god
the huntsman has the trail you grace and
sent out the hounds it won't be long now
until the white heart is cornered your
prize is within reach
we're going to catch it for you so then
you can kill it there is another choice
beyond casterly rock
prince
oh
aegon
boy just turned two on her yes
but it would cease the endless proposals
for renewal
what a great reaction to that
that's so disturbing
hey two years old that kid's gonna be a
man soon enough
no
buddy
soon he's gonna be taking over the
karaoke machine
welcomes the hotel
targaryen
king jahirus ruled over half a century
of peace while his children drove him to
the edge of madness
his daughters in particular
it is tradition your grace for women am
i right
you believe that your son
saharwin break bones
the strongest night in the seven
kingdoms
is the best match for an era
it would seem to me the best match for
rhaenyra is the son of the seasick
seleno
we must pray of course that lana
survives the fighting in the stepstones
[Music]
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
i have no choice but to princess
what oh my god what's happening is the
war coming here
let's jump into the worst
place
right across the ridge
it's behind those trees
[Music]
damn
[Music]
whoa
wow
oh
poor
it's not the predator
it's it's down it didn't get it
i swear it was the way out of my abyss
of grief and regret
that naming her air would begin to set
things right oh it did i never imagined
i would remarry
and i would have a stun
what if i was wrong
ah man it's tough being a king
believe me i know
ugh
[Music]
my god
i don't like this
[Music]
ah cool
[Laughter]
sign for the gods
have you convinced the king to make
aegon air
aegon like his namesake was born to rule
the seven kingdoms you mustn't ignore
the certain truth that if rhaenyra were
to step over regan to ascend the throne
the realm would tear itself apart
it's a really disturbing painting in the
background
[Laughter]
the road ahead is uncertain but the end
is clear
aegon will be king you must guide
viserys towards reason
as a woman i don't think a woman should
be sitting on the throne we are
impulsive and emotional
when ira has come of haiti
she must need to marry a high lord who
will honor her defend her and serve her
he's missing two fingers
well corliss and prince damon are losing
their war
badly by all accounts
this is a plea for aid
is it better for the realm of the crab
feeder thrives
or is vanquished
and aegon should be king
i think we're done talking here
aid is sailing to the stepstones
did he make call for help he would
sooner die
do you not think my decision correct
it is no consequence to what i think
as i'm often reminded
[Laughter]
why must every effort on your behalf be
resisted as if to the death because you
mean to replace me with alice and
hightower son
you have them in hand now
you have no further use for me
oh i do not seek to replace you child
search him out
find one that pleases you
as i did
the king's guard
yeah kristen
they work so well together
their scene work is amazing
our food quickly dwindles say for what
we can fish from the sea i would say we
have a fortnight perhaps a bit longer
with strict rationing what a reveal shot
show me the knight who will march into
that helping nephew and i will show you
a madness damon damon is why we are
losing
he at least is fighting this war what
role have you played in his council
uncle other the master of complaints
enough
it's
pretty good burn if you do not seize
control of this war my lord the crabs
will soon die on all of us
he holds such a presence
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is madness i have ordered 10 ships
and 2 000 men to set sail from king's
landing i shall pray nightly to the gods
for your safe return
oh
it's our boy from earlier now
three years ago
no the beginning of this episode yeah
i thought the beginning was three years
ago oh maybe
what
i mean isn't he being the human bait
[Music]
to lure out
i suppose so i suppose a white flag
would be a good ploy
[Music]
he's making sure it's not bait
what is your story sir
holy crap jeez
oh man one man army right here
[Music]
david
[Laughter]
with this whole thing by myself
[Music]
nicely done
wow nicely done
ah good good thing he got hit right
there
come on dragons where are you
ah the hilt on that thing come on
dragons burn them
[Music]
the [ __ ] where are they guys
damon's a bastard but we had a plan
oh
oh hell yeah
oh they were too busy looking up man
yeah too busy looking
good
smart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't yell when there's right above you
nice definitely the thumbnail okay
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
isn't battle glorious
the ferocity of this man is
awesome oh my god did he get him
it's so
in half
so ferocious
wow
[Music]
my man
my man
[Music]
awesome
wow that was awesome that was hard
that's hardcore
well it just keeps getting better and
better
ah that was
that was awesome what a great book in
it's like the start
of damon getting into the fight at least
is what it perceived to me as right
because
the guy who was suffering at the
guy was suffering on the ground at the
beginning when the crab feeder was
killing him yeah he was saying my prince
will come and all that yeah but it
seemed like oh my god he's actually
joining the fight yeah or something are
you saying something right yeah yeah so
that was the beginning of the war then
this is um the end of it and i gotta say
like normally
time jumps can actually upset me when
i'm watching uh a series there's a lot
of time like i want to see the
development of all those things i want
to see what happens in between i want to
see it you know grow out and
this is like the rare case where you're
getting so many time jumps in between
episodes
that i'm like i imagine there's got to
be a point where we're not time jumping
that much yeah like okay this is the
next day and not like like like a few
years later
yeah months years yeah so i imagine
we'll probably get to that point
sometime um
maybe maybe not but the way they handle
is because they stick so true to the
emotional core of all these characters
and
the actors i think do such a good job at
filling in
the memories in between that we did not
get to see that you can feel the passage
of time and you could feel the history
and whatever
either strain or awkward tension or
conversations that have taken place or
weariness
and so everyone is doing such a good job
and it's such a rare occasion to me to
to watch something with so many
different time jumps and to still be
fully engrossed right when you catch up
to okay we're three years ahead and five
two seconds later i'm like it just
engrossed yeah in what's going on as
opposed to it would have looked i've
seen some of this that's normally where
i'm at with the shows i that's the
problem that i usually have with time
jumps and shows and this does not give
me that problem and it it's just a
testament to
how strong and rich
like everything just
firing on all cylinders in every
direction
and uh
yeah good show it's a good show
that's a good show
so
yeah anyway john like i couldn't agree
with you more talk about something
specific please well yeah no i think
it's hard to do
this kind of time jumping
in a show like this because i think
they're good at making it feel
deliberate sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it feels just like i don't
know let's move along but yeah like this
feels like the most notable
bullet points or you know like if you're
reading a history of something these
seem like the pivotal moments and yeah i
love
the way that they're able to balance
this you know
family drama almost with all this
politics and they even come out and say
he's like i'm so tired of talking
politics and yet
you know that's inescapable for people
in this position and i i loved the back
and forth of the relationship between
viserys and rhaenyra throughout this
episode and everybody coming up to him
and being like hey listen you gotta you
gotta change and you've got your son now
you got a gone you gotta change the
whole you know way forward for uh you
know your air and stuff like that right
and and watching the struggle and
watching him become more and more
depressed on this ironic day of
celebration and watching as everything
kind of
again seems to be deteriorating not only
in his physical health and all that but
also in the situations it's like
watching as they bring in not the white
heart but just a regular old stag and
seeing the sort of begrudging
disappointment like i think the way that
they're whittling away at his character
is great because it feels very alive and
natural but i'm also kind of i'm always
unsure as to where it's going to go and
what he's going to reveal and then like
you pointed out like his back and forth
with uh millie alcock who's currently
rhaenyra like she's so
she is so great and the two of them are
such different characters but yeah that
unspoken
both
tension but occasional understanding
between them is is really beautiful and
i think
you know i mean game of thrones
world you know you come in associating
with you know lots of interesting and
large characters but i also feel like
certain people need to bring out that
intimacy and i think they do it really
nicely with these these two you know
yeah uh
and they're like they have these people
position like there's people arguing
that damon should have been king
just because man brother and then
you have the aegon and i know the name
aegon targaryen
so
unfortunately it's been a couple years
since i've seen game of thrones yeah so
i'm like okay i don't remember the
details so is that confirmation that
this child will be kidding yeah or is he
just named after a previous age
yeah yeah so i like i like that i
haven't taken the time to like let me go
revisit all game of thrones because it
helped i feel like actually kind of
forgetting some some details helps me
just enjoy this experience for what it
is
and uh instead of like thinking about
what's going to come next you know
and just taking like being the moment
with the show as opposed to where the
destination is
so um
you have that with aegon targaryen but
they really show that would rinera
i always get confused on how to
pronounce it rhaenyra right yeah with
renera how
she's the most capable one if anyone is
to be heir to the targaryen throne it
should be her
because she's got the strategy down i
mean she's that's already solved like
she's solved problems everyone else is
like i deserve it or damon's just a of a
a wild crazy
batman yeah
and i i love everything that they flesh
out with her like her performances
carries so much weight in every moment
she's on screen
so to like everyone does an amazing job
and it's cool that they're like the
titular characters feel like they're
damon and renera and
both of them
very different roles on all accounts
and
you know i think that we're supposed to
be getting an older i think the one
thing that imdb kind of sorry if i'm
spoiling something here if you didn't
know this but um
so you could click off if you want i
think on imdb they do say that there's
going to be an older rain era at some
point yeah based off the way this shows
time jumping around
probably gonna get one um
and it makes me sad to know that we're
probably not gonna be hanging out with
her yeah she's so good she's so she's so
awesome and i root for her so much and i
feel for her so much that it's kind of
painful knowing like oh man we're not
just going to like hang out with her for
like five seasons that's gonna be her
show yeah yeah
um
but i'm sure that whoever fills in the
the slot the seat for her would be great
and because every every every
interaction that she has just carries so
much history to it and the way they
i think every actor does a good job on
where they're at at this point in here
like viserys uh he has just got through
the ringer oh that that dude has just
become more and more dejected as
as time has gone on and it's like he's
gotten the thing he always dreamt of and
he just seems like he's in a worse place
mentally and emotionally than he's ever
been in his entire existence yeah like i
made a joke about it that it's only been
three years but he's aged like eight
he's like balding yeah yeah yeah
it's like just it doesn't seem like he
cares at all to like keep his face
trimmed no like he looks like unc like
there's a he just looks older he doesn't
look on chem nester they look he looks a
lot older and that time has really taken
his tone the stress has really weighed
on him it's like when someone gets
nominated for president and then they
age like 20
because it's got to be hard to be in
that position and two he's surrounded by
so many connivers and so many
you know people who are actively trying
to manipulate him and so it must be you
can feel the loneliness and you can feel
the despair in him because of that well
he's surrounded by so much just
cold-hearted politics and he's someone
with a with a heart you know whether or
not whether or not you like some of the
decisions this guy makes
and he's not the greatest father he's he
makes an effort yeah whether or not the
the word he lands is the thing you agree
on i wouldn't call the character
unlikable even though he's made a a step
or two that's not a real likable
decision yeah yeah he's definitely not
an unlikable character because the guy
really does care and it's like he he
would like to find some type of reprieve
some type of balance where he can
be king do the political [ __ ] but also
like i saw my my daughter marry someone
she loves and i just want to want to
enjoy life a little bit i want to
celebrate love a little bit and all we
ever do is
the political game of it and i i thought
like watching his dissent over his drunk
like they even did a good job on the
time span as he got progressively more
drunk and more
more uh more angry and then went into
just very vulnerable and lamenting a lot
of a lot of the sorrow and worry that
he's feeling uh i thought such an
excellent character it's great great
writing and acting and uh
and that whole thing with the what kind
of animals
it's a deer it is a deirdre essentially
yeah they uh a heart a heart yes
on the white heart shoot like the way
that was contrasted was so well done oh
yeah well and i love the way that that
plays they they have a couple
discussions in this episode about
different like bits of symbolism like i
saw in a dream you know by this child
born with this crown or inversely you
have or across the spectrum you have
this ritual this sort of blessing from
the gods of oh the white heart appears
and that's
could just be the superstition of man
but also it could mean something and
then two it appears to rhaenyra after
this again like this really
uncomfortable moment when they slaughter
the regular one where you can just tell
it's just not like you can you can tell
for uh uh um
viserys that just it's just not working
and yeah you watch his filter descend
and it's
it's such a well-drawn triangle because
there's so many characters but i feel
like the presences of the main
targaryens are really well done and even
on the opposite side of the spectrum
with daemon because it's like you get
the most of rhaenyra and you get you
know a lot of viserys and you see their
relationship and their estrangement
though they are so close but then you
also get the estrangement from damon and
the way they use him i think is really
cool and really rewarding because in
these two episodes since the first one
he's he's in the first one a lot but
since he's been sort of banished to
dragonstone or has just sort of been
ignored to be of his own devices over
there like when he enters there's just
as much presence you know as if he'd
been here the whole time and every
moment like i love the way they had him
be so deliberate and stoic and it's like
he gets this letter and he reads it he
barely speaks and they play it so up
close in his face like he's i don't
think he spoke one word the whole
episode yeah i think you're thinking
back i think you're probably right and i
i
love how gripping that is and the way
that that character in just a couple
moments like he gets the letter and you
can tell there's there's a rush of
things happening in some way you bet
it's kind of a relief or that there's
some kind of emotional pain to like oh
my brother is finally deciding to help
but also on the flip side we've we've
lost so many ranks and we've done all
the hard work and now he's going to come
in and help and make it some kind of
victory like no i gotta go deal with
this myself and even though we haven't
gotten like a lot of
big exposition from him lately like his
life and growth feels so vital even
despite all that and even though he is
quite removed from everybody right now
and uh yeah just
the whole battle that led to was
incredible oh yeah i mean the the the
both battles at the beginning in the end
you know they i think what they really
do well with the battle sequences um in
this episode is they they utilize their
environment and atmosphere very well
like in the nighttime sequence the the
way they have the dragon kind of be
illuminated by just like everyone and
everything's just kind of eliminated by
fires it's almost like roger
deacon's-esque
that nice orange light yeah yeah yeah it
was great it was awesome uh so the
vision so i was like this looks freaking
amazing it's beautiful to behold and
then of course um in the final battle
with you could feel the the ocean waves
and the weather and and the fog the mist
and i i loved how all that was executed
so i think utilizing that and then it
was all like scuzzy and up close and
messy and times you can't even really
tell what's going on then at times you
catch it the last thing like oh that's
what's going on oh my god you know so it
gets it has this great
pulsating punch to it and the crab
feeder carried so much presence and i i
do wish we got a little bit more with
the crab feeder that was as cool as a
moment that was in a reveal
i was like damn you've been like setting
the homeboy up since the first episode
yeah i want to see some kind of actual
pulling back of the curtain on him or
something i don't know like a scene with
him yeah i mean not that we needed like
a crazy dialogue driven scene but uh
just to spend more time with him due to
the fact that whenever they cut to him
it seems like they had such a specific
illustration to draw and especially with
their the way they captured it
photography wise
and
just the mood and and the the the vibe
of whatever he was there
was so
palpable it just gets you yeah and
you're sucked into this gorgeous
darkness this is very striking yeah
so i wanted to spend more and i kind of
wanted to see that like final battle you
know like as much as i love it's a part
of me that just
truly loves the way it was handled don't
get me wrong i really love the part was
handled and there's the flip side of me
it's like i just
want a little bit more well yeah
it is the one maybe thing that feels a
little and i'll and i'll reserve full
judgment until we see past this because
you never know
what might still remain of you know this
group and and what they do you know
obviously the the crab feeder has people
who follow him so yeah it's the one
thing though
with the time jumping and stuff that
maybe does feel at this moment just on
first watch a little slight or a little
bit like this seemed like a such a vital
threat and such a important
piece that if it's just wrapped up now
and we're not gonna really ever think
about that again i am a little taken
aback by that but there'll be after
effects for sure from the from the
conquering of this yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i mean it's such an important you
know strategic part of the realm and
everything that yeah like there will be
fallout from this but at the same time
yeah part of me just as a genre viewers
just like man i just want to see more of
this crab carnage
i mean the
that was just all their people right um
like damon and and um yeah valerian and
the velour valorians the valorians
with them that was just their people
yeah right it wasn't it wasn't the
reinforcements yeah they didn't show up
so that's what was so smart about us was
damon's most badass moment here was
motivated by emotion
yeah because he's like i'm not even
gonna wait for these reinforcements like
thanks but no thanks let's just go in
and take care of this yeah no matter how
hopeless this looks we're gonna do it
yeah so
this is awesome to me man yeah
this is great and then even with like um
the way they've been fleshing out uh
alison
and
like her
her relationship with viserys i actually
really liked how she entered the room
and it became about you know the
necessity to enter the battle and what
that represents and it wasn't about
um
whoa i just already forgot it aegon
aegon yeah it wasn't long it wasn't
about uh aegon targaryen the way otto
wanted it to be yeah
because auto in a lot of ways seems like
the little finger of this show sure uh
but he's doing he's definitely doing his
own thing like you could see why why why
uh he's trusted and then in private
you're like you're a sick son of a [ __ ]
he seems so like he seems so believably
compassionate and understanding yeah
in a in a more public setting great
false sincerity yeah from that guy but
in in um
because he's
he's manipulating and using his own
daughter it's it's disturbing it's it's
disgusting it's really disgusting what
he's doing
he's using his daughter yeah and he's
the one who's like maybe ronero should
marry aegon why not you know yeah yeah
well anything to get aegon to be king
yeah you know yeah yeah
and eve and oh yeah and the guy who
plays that he's in halloween that's he's
he's the podcast yeah he plays the last
god i was trying to figure it out it
took me a while to pinpoint it and i was
like yeah you're the dude in the
podcasting in halloween and uh he's
american in that no he's british in that
i can't was he american
totally forgot actually he's still
british in there
because i think they're a little fish
out of watery but i'm not i'd have to go
back and look yeah the halloween remake
obviously not the original yeah robson
halloween oh yeah uh 2018. yeah so he
was um oh not the remake the sequel god
damn it yes the the official party
real
halloween too
yes so
he he he was fun to watch too because
you know he's like yeah he's a lannister
all right who'd you say his his brother
was i it wasn't tywin it was like thai
tygon or something like that close to
taiwan yeah yeah no i love that too
because they they're good at playing on
the fact that yeah it's like a lannister
or any other recognizable house name
shows up and you have like this
preconceived notion and i love that
i don't know this is a testament to the
way they were able to build these
characters where you're like this guy is
definitely a lannister although you know
he's not the slickest lannister out
there he seems like just kind of another
one of their ranks and by the time he
gets a game of thrones you know
lannister always pays his debts and and
with the lannisters they they are
they are the top dogs
right i'm remembering that correctly
right yeah so at least once you get out
there yeah yeah so atlantis so the
lannisters are the top and
and then you're here you're seeing this
jason guy be so submissive
towards his king you know even when the
king is getting upset with him yeah and
how he's just like kind of backing away
and he's just striving for more power so
i think they got all these wonderful
chess pieces in play
uh i don't really know
how this is all going to turn to the
biggest pile of dog [ __ ] for everyone
here oh this is going to torture but
it's going to name everybody yeah it
just seems like this could go wrong this
could go wrong this they're all probably
gonna go wrong in some way yeah and
that's part of what makes it so fun to
watch the drama because the drama is
never boring it's never boring and never
feels like it's slowing the show down
it's like great game of thrones stuff
because
there's always something deeper
underneath what's being talked about and
what's advancing in terms of plot and
you always get the sense that there's
there's some type of
cunning behavior like the the lionel
character the one that looks like john
bailey seems to be the one who who
really just wants to offer some good
pieces
i love the council on that guy yeah and
i love that character too because over
these three episodes just seeing him in
brief glimpses like that is an
association that has for me kind of
grown each time so like this time when
when yeah viserys cuts him off i love
the way he played that where he's like i
get i get what you're insinuating thanks
but no
here's an actually good idea and they're
i think that's
you know you sit here watching this and
for me part of my brain afterwards it's
like trying to figure out the alchemy of
how they write like this and i think
they have a game of thrones at least the
good era of game of thrones and now this
show they're really good at
both
giving you these stakes like these first
three episodes have had a lot of
tensions and a lot of different stakes
crashing together and we've had at least
a couple battles but you can feel the
sense that this is not the end of
anything this is like the early
squabbles leading to a much bigger
conflict most likely and through
characters
like all the different you know small
table folks and and everybody kind of
that we peer in on they're really good
at showing the direct link between the
people and those motivations and these
big
you know situations of armies clashing
and and you know statecraft and
differing ideologies and all that like
they i think the reason they're so good
at jumping back and forth between big
battles and then big drama is because
yeah like they really draw that line
between
you know the whims of people and these
conflicts and the way in which you know
everyone's different position in the
class system and emotional experience
all affects this
i don't know they seem really good at
yeah kind of drawing never letting you
forget about that so that no motion or
action feels arbitrary
yeah i love it i think it's great the
music is
haunting yeah it's just gorgeous music
and i think the way they especially in
the final battle the way how they
captured so everything's just so up
close and personal a lot of these like
really intimate profile shots you know
it's like the chaos it's the you really
feel like you're there and you're in the
chaos of it
yeah this is awesome this is really
great and even the way they're flushing
out last thing i i i mean i like the i
like the kristen character a lot too
like she should be with him um
absolutely should but the even the
relationship with allison and rinera of
how
you could tell that there's even
complexity there like she hasn't gone
you know full
you know cold queen in this you know
she's very she she's
still craves that connection with rinera
and and doesn't feel right
about trying to manipulate at least
right now
cut to like four years and later in the
next episode yeah
um
but um but allison you know
you could tell doesn't feel right about
trying to oust an era from from the
throne yeah and uh
you can tell how uncomfortable she is
yeah by her position
um so
i don't know i i hope it doesn't just
time jump so much every episode
right now it hasn't lost me at all i
could see a version though where i'm
like
come on let's let's just let's stay in
this
couple month period you know
yeah i i hope that there is at least a
very smooth transition point before we
we hop in i want to finish it feels like
now would be a good point yeah that's
the thing and i i don't know like and
hey it all depends on how they handle
the episode but but yeah you you feel
like if you are going to jump enough
time to get different actors i think
emotionally you would want to feel like
you sent off that iteration of the
character or you know at least enough
for
you know that actor or whatever is when
when it is a situation like this where
especially millie alcock is just so
engrossing to watch and such great
casting
uh yeah you know oh yeah she's [ __ ]
brilliant yeah and it's like i love
watching this performance and just
having this idea that will probably i
doubt it's gonna be like little fat
jumps forward it's probably gonna be
like a full-on jump forward and we
probably won't see her again except
maybe flashbacks
so that's you know
they don't have to but for me as a
viewer i'm like i want to feel like i
really got the the richest amount of
time with this portrayal before moving
on she's done a lot of work holy crap
yeah the first thing i'm seeing from her
yeah i haven't seen any of these things
she's been and i'm looking at her imdb
right now
jeepers oh my god i want to catch up on
she has booked so many tv mini series
she's done so much that's good that's
good so much tv she's like like a series
regular on a bunch of tv shows
pretty much since she started she wasn't
far from house of the dragon she just
got out aged yeah
but yeah wow my god that's like
why don't you go to work i know
jesus no seriously like there's there's
a lot of great casting on this show and
there's a lot of satisfying performance
work but you know yeah i think
especially because this is the first
time i've seen her i'm just like ah like
i would watch this character across all
the seasons in her hands not to slight
whoever is taking over but
she does have that really young look and
she's like she's 22.
and she i believe she was like 15 years
old
i think maybe in this episode she was on
the verge of of she was like 17. maybe
but but yeah i mean we've seen her since
she was like at least 14 and i believed
it each time
yeah yeah yeah um all right guys well
thank you for being here um be sure to
subscribe and keep a lookout for a
reaction in the next episode
i'm loving this show i really am i'm i'm
loving it currently loving it more than
another fantasy show oh no
oh don't don't tell me what it is but
this is i'm enjoying this one a lot more
and this one didn't cost as much
i don't know what you would i don't
can't figure it out this one's a lot
more interesting
anyway guys we'll see
[Music]